one of the things we talked about a lot
and we thought about hundred
years and this concept of Wishing Upon a
Star that resonated for all of
us Disney has this very rich deep Legacy
of I want
songs and so we wanted that same
fabric but also looking towards
something fresh and new and our
songwriters Julia Michaels and Benjamin
rice brought exactly that with this wish
so I look the Stars guide Asha is
beautifully played by Ariana she's full
of joy full of life but she's also like
oo squirrel exactly Ariana is amazing
she truly embodies the essence of Asha
she delivers
[Music]
everything this wish is Asha wanting
more for the people in her town I was so
inspired by that and I knew that this
song needed to be this very big very
Grand
moment there's so many aspects of a
music that has the deep meaning of our
Classics but also completely
original to me Disney songs those are
things that live beyond the
[Music]
movie